we're not backing down we've had a very
bad deal with Mexico very bad deal with
Canada's goal NAFTA I don't think I
don't think you're gonna have a trade
would I understand if we get if we get a
great NAFTA agreement and ambassador
light Heiser's trying to do that that
would be a great thing for the American
people but at this point in time
25% of steel 10% on aluminum no country
exclusions firm line in the sand nobody
wins a trade war especially in these
globalized days the United States when
we're so dependent on goods coming in
and going out for our competitiveness
voices across the spectrum they're on
the idea of these new tariffs let's
bring in our panel to talk about it Mike
Allen co-founder of Axios Molly
Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalist and Tom Bevan
RealClearPolitics co-founder and
publisher welcome to all of you okay so
the president says today there's no way
we're backing down and yet there's been
pushback domestically and
internationally Tom do you think that
when we get this official announcement
from him it's gonna be what he's
outlined so far do you think he
moderates it in any way i trump so who
knows right we don't know exactly what
he what he's gonna do and even people
around him don't necessarily know what
he's going to do I think he might a
little bit I mean this is a campaign
promise in fact this is something that
Trump's talked about for decades about
America getting ripped off and needing
to have these kind of you know good
deals put in place and have fair trade
so I think by and large he looks like
he's not gonna back off I expect he
probably won't he may moderate a little
bit on the margins maybe on the numbers
but this is the first real break that
he's had with his party on economic
issues they've been with him on tax cuts
on deregulation but now you have speaker
Paul Ryan coming out and and basically
blasting he's got almost no support his
party for this but I think that doesn't
matter to him I think he's still gonna
push forward with it something he has
talked about for decades
you mentioned the speaker Paul Ryan so
we know that last week senator Cornyn
one of the top Republicans in the Senate
said basically we may have hearings on
this whole tariff thing because we have
some oversight of the executive branch
on these issues the speaker Ryan's a
spokesperson today Ashley strong saying
we are extremely worried about the
consequences of a trade war and are
urging the White House to not advance
with this plan here's what Sarah Sanders
had to say in the briefing in response
to that
we have a great relationship with
speaker Ryan we're gonna continue to
have one but that doesn't mean we have
to agree on everything what do you make
of a Molly well this is certainly an
area where Donald Trump deviates from
traditional Republican orthodoxy and
it's really weird because the first year
of his presidency was really marked by a
commitment to free-market economics you
had corporate tax reform you had
individual tax cuts you had broad
deregulation and now you have kind of
the opposite you have an increase in
spending you have plans to increase
spending even more and now I believe
that regulation not deregulation is good
for international markets and that first
year you saw the stock market really do
well the think was a 30% increase in the
in the first year and recently you've
seen a 6% decrease in the stock market
now it's not to say that the only thing
that matters is corporations bottom
lines and I think Donald Trump has been
consistent that he believes this is part
of some larger philosophy in that he
needs to show strength here I don't know
if the market is gonna allow that what
do you make of it Mike because yeah the
market is all over the place since this
announcement it is but the president is
now tweeting about other indicators he's
now found other favorites and the
president is going to have the last word
on this he's going to have his way
Tigers can have all the hearings and
they can be was worried as they want to
be but that's what this is all about the
president has been saying since he was
elected literally he would say bring me
tariffs and Axios over the weekend had
amazing reporting from Jonathan Swan
saying that there was a showdown in
January in the Oval Office where the
president had the AIDS fight it out Gary
Cohn for the free trade and the Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross on the other side
the president called Gary Kona Clovis
in front of others Gary Cohn moves over
to a couch in the Oval Office and him
moving over to the couch that's when
this really was settled the president
knew that he was going to get what he
had been saying he was gonna get his
tariffs well does have authority here
though I mean the Constitution says that
this should be set by Congress any type
of tariff or thing like this you saw
that the president was appealing to
national security concerns saying that
you need factories and steel resources
out of national security concerns which
is not to say there's not an argument
that but this is a way of because our
laws permit you to enact tariffs for
national security concerns by the
president
this is his attempt to do an end run
around the Constitution I mean you saw
how that went over with Canada one of
our best allies they said for him to
invoke the idea of national security
with respect to products that we import
into the u.s. is completely unacceptable
I mean Tom it didn't go over well in
Canada many other places oh and it's not
going over well around the globe in
general and the thing is if Trump is
using this as a negotiating tactic it's
sort of undermines the argument that it
was a national security threat to begin
with well and it's also true that the
u.s. really does have lower tariffs than
every other country out there and for
everybody to be acting like this is
unacceptable for us to do well if it's
unacceptable for us it's also
unacceptable for all these other
countries that punish us corporations
and whatnot and they should they should
understand that they don't get to do
whatever they want and that we won't do
anything in response even if we know
from from broad economic research the
tariffs are just a tax on people and so
they're not generally a good idea that I
really did think Shen they're gonna be
more cutouts in there were I thought
maybe Canada maybe you're now they're
saying individual companies can you
imagine what that's like waving a red
cape at K Street over here imagine what
a lobbying frequent that will be that's
gonna be expensive okay and it's this
idea of whether it is negotiating the
president's talking about this now in
the context of NAFTA negotiations he had
a three-parter tweet we're just gonna
read you the first one he says we have
large trade trade deficits with Mexico
and Canada NAFTA which is under
renegotiation right now has been a bad
deal for us a massive relocation of
companies and jobs tariffs on steel and
aluminum will only come off if new and
fair NAFTA agreement is signed he then
goes on to talk more about Canada and
Mexico
but do you think that NAFTA negotiations
may buy Canada and Mexico some relief on
these tariffs and is that what this is
all about or in part I actually think a
lot of this is about trying to
reposition ourselves versus China I
think that Donald Trump really
understands that China is this economic
powerhouse and that there needs to be
some kind of economic actions taken
against China and that all this other
stuff is kind of a precursor to that
much more important and larger debate
and what about the fact that it seems to
be pitting us industry some of them
against each other because we heard from
farming and bottling come
agriculture last week saying listen if
you helped seal in some way you're going
to end up hurting us again typical
Republican sort of philosophy on this is
is you're not supposed to be picking
winners and losers than the economy
protecting some not protecting others
and this does generate sort of an
opportunity to go down a slippery slope
where you'll have all these other
industries microphone GK Street getting
involved lobbying for it you know
protections for their industries as well